well it's an off day for the golden
knights they face the ducks tomorrow and
again
on sunday sports director chris matthews
joins us live here in the studio with
more
on the nights as they chase the first
place colorado right yeah they're having
lots of trouble here right now certainly
a challenge right now because vegas
they can't make company ground on the
avalanche because they just keep on
winning also
now they don't have much time to catch
up they're only 14 more games left in
the regular season
vegas is done with the kings now they've
won six of hate against los angeles
now they got two with the ducks over the
next four days
golden knights are a 4-1 against anaheim
this season knights have scored 15
against that team but they've given up
10.
here's an interesting number vegas has
had 18 different players who have
registered at least one point against
anaheim
now last night's win over the kings was
big because they take that momentum into
a pair
with anaheim a real good four line game
but those first three lines all have the
ability to really put some pressure on
the other team offensively
[Applause]
the last shift is the same as the next
shift i mean i thought the
the the noisy line was uh
flying all game kentucky and the yen
mark stepped in and played
a really good game probably the
type of player exact type of player that
we needed and tonight he showed that
all right now another note from that
game marc-andre fleury is now
all alone in fourth place among the
all-time career leaders and goalies he
passed up at belfor last night
he's five away from passing roberto
luongo and moving into third all by
himself
boy he'll never catch martin brodeur
though he has 691
career wins